[Musique]
trois gagnants phone m2 j'espère qu'on
va faire beaucoup mieux
il va falloir qu'on mène une campagne de
proximité remettre tous les systèmes en
place et avancer je crois que tu as bien
démarrer là avaient tous ses meetings
avec la campagne des copains que je mène
déjà depuis septembre 2006 sur le
terrain près d'une cinquantaine de
déplacement dans les territoires et les
terroirs de france à la rencontre des
forces vives de la ruralité
j'ai pu entendre la france j'ai pu
entendre les français les écouter et
proposer un projet ce projet que nous
allons porter c'est le projet pour la
ruralité d'abord mais qui est tout à
fait transposable dans les villes parce
que vous savez ruralité ça rime avec
quartier on peut faire du développement
économique créer des emplois on peut
soutenir notre agriculture mettre fin la
fermeture des services publics lutter
contre la désertification médico-social
porter une autre europe
une autre écologie est également peu
possible dans notre pays une écologie
incitatives respectueuses de l'homme et
ses activités un projet collectif
un projet de solidarité dans notre pays
qu'on peut facilement transposer dans
les villes ruralité ça rime avec
quartier il n'y a pas de français de
seconde zone
il n'y a pas de territoire de seconde
zone dans ce pays tout le monde a droit
à sa part de progrès et développement
elle est là on peut d'ailleurs cela ces
territoires on peut insérer le problème
de l'écologie parce que les verts avec
leur système banquier très sectaire est
le nôtre qui est incitative les points
qu'on doit pouvoir faire les clients de
rentrer tous à l'écologie de salon sont
en heures passées il est temps de passer
à une écologie incitatives une écologie
des équilibres qui va respecter l'homme
et ses activités qui va donner à tout le
monde à la fois les moyens et l'intérêt
d'agir bio d'agir écologique parce que
ça coûtera moins cher aujourd'hui c'est
du luxe et il faut combattre justement
et rejeter cette écologie punitive
portés par les verts et c'est bien pour
ça que je n'ai pas signé d'ailleurs le
pacte écologique de nicolas hulot à ces
guerres parce que cette écologie ne
fonctionne qu'à coups de taxes de
punition de restriction de sanction
d'exclusion qui va faire de nous
valdé réserve d'indiens ça suffit les
vieilles recettes du passé qui justement
ne marche pas puisque l'environnement va
plus mal aujourd'hui qui à 25 ans est
justement que ça marche pas il est temps
de passer à autre chose
il nous faut une écologie humaine une
écologie réaliste nécrologie d'
équilibre une écologie incitatives et je
crois que la raison est de développer le
territoire comment comme on le dit
comment le fait chasseurs pêcheurs et
que tu as aimé car la culture
c'est un pas important il faut connaître
grogne un peu plus les problèmes de la
ruralité justement c'est qu'elle est
composée de minorités les agriculteurs
les chasseurs les commerçants les
artisans les élus des petites communes
et qui tous connaissent d'énormes
problèmes parce qu'ils sont sacrifiés en
est minoritaire
résultat les pouvoirs publics de gloss
comme de droite nous oublie complètement
on a besoin d'inverser cette tendance
d'assurer une politique d'aménagement du
territoire équilibré où tout le monde
aura sa part de progrès sa part de
développement c'est ça qui compte c'est
une égalité des chances pour tous
alors il s'agit de soutenir par les
charges par une baisse de la fiscalité
l'installation en les artisans des
commerçants des petites entreprises
surtout si ce sont des jeunes et les
chômeurs qui veulent sur vous lancez
faire de la reprise d'activité mais en
même temps il faut soutenir l'activité
rurale traditionnelle notamment
l'agriculture
aujourd'hui l'europe et la
mondialisation sont en train de casser
nos agriculteurs moi je suis désolé il
faut qu'on soutienne l'agriculture
française il faut qu'on soutienne les
années
deux français à qui font des produits et
des productions de qualité
l'europe avec l'élargissement à faire
entrer nos principaux concurrents
agricole résultat notre agriculture
disparaît et il n'y a pas de volonté
politique à gauche comme à droite de
défendre nos agriculteurs il faut une
préférence à la fois communautaire une
préférence française pour les
productions
ouais et bien et c'est là où on pourra
aussi intégré parce que j'ai produit un
territoire qu'on y vit on a notre
qualité de vie
notre façon de vivre c'est toutes ces
traditions qui font la vie de chacun les
différences entre les régions et
différence entre les sommes et peut-être
aussi plus de liberté
ça peut être à liberté chassés de pêcher
et de vivre tout sépare la campagne mais
il faut l'égalité des chances dans une
france des différences une france des
différences qui respectera les cultures
de chacun sans verser dans le
communautarisme une france des
différences qui respectera notre
patrimoine historique qui respectera nos
langues nationales de façon
complémentaire justement à cette fameuse
identité nationale dont on a tous besoin
parce qu'elle sert de repère dans notre
société et à côté de ça il faut qu'on
puisse bien vivre au pays
basé sur nos traditions basé sur la
culture mais sur un projet d'avenir des
racines fortes pour un avenir serein
[Musique]